yeah
I will stand by you forever
I have to go shoot a main Channel video
now yeah who Monday isn't alright
alright I think it's Friday say my big
team for just fans you made to Team
Fortress videos before really fun
universe of being because it's just
really cartoon characters fighting nerf
we're no nerf we just want to do a cool
action scene and nerf or nothing we just
want to do a cool action scene hey how
are you are you filming
yeah are you guys inside you gonna see
this guy let's be honest I swear I feel
like since I've had the beard I bond
with dogs more okay when you're ready
when you're ready oh you guys
passionately subscribe to progressed I
like you yeah cinematography is another
tool to tell a story an action scene
that becomes doubly important because
one action scenes that have less
dialogue and a lot more body language
and to the style of shots are using an
action scene will convey what's
happening what emotion you should be
feeling you remember back in the vlogs
as a moment where Sam is saying hey you
and I are going to be in this piece
you'll meet a DP and say 100% correct
because when Sam and I are in a piece we
can't shoot it at the same time and
Carmichael who you know is the guy
literally behind the camera right now
he's been shooting a lot of stuff for us
for the salmon eco Channel he's also
been shooting some stuff for his
girlfriend's channel and so it's
cinematography skills to get a little
bit better and I figured you know what
else is the behind the scenes we've
gotten over 230 submission which is yeah
which is awesome but someone's got to go
through it and find out who of these
people we should actually bring in for
an interview that's me this card is a
little more comfortable than I thought
it'd be but it's just as big as I
thought it'd be
there's the easiest jobless area it's
been a very painstaking but interesting
process because it's cool to see how
many people are really interested in
what we're doing and want to be a part
of it this is my t-shirt you're too slow
just like it's probably
two small goes but I'm gonna put it on
for the camera and then that vest is on
backwards
that's funny hey guys when I came I
swear to god I'm like they're gonna give
me little clothes I know it that's what
I was like yo should I bring anything
you're like now comfortable shoes I'm
like I'm wearing a little close
six-five 270 pounds put the camera down
for a second actually I'm 260 but like
hey you look like you slim down I'm
lucky item 250 it probably is guest
starring as the head obviously because
ladies scout you idiot come on I'm 6
foot 9 280 pounds of course looking
forward to this all week
imagine that's the hardest-hitting nerd
friend that I've ever experienced in my
life
ah Yogesh stop yes anymore - OH
as I see myself there too when I was in
college I was making you know reels
trying to get work making HD videos
interns will come here and I don't judge
them this Sunday on the Internet live
streamed Sam judges all the interns no
no that's not really happening but I'll
be really funny with it if we actually
Facebook live streamed all the interns
coming in and judging them went to
meeting developing cool projects with
the movie studio all right yeah exactly
we've got by